let f of X equal negative x squared plus
ax plus B over x squared plus CX Plus D
where ABC and D are unknown constants
which of the following is a possible
graph of y is equal to f of X and it
tells dashed lines indicate asymptotes
so this is really interesting here and
they give us four choices we see four
from a three of them right now then if I
scroll a little bit over you can see
choice D and so I encourage you to pause
the video and think about how we can
figure it out because it is interesting
because they haven't given us a lot of
details they haven't given us what these
coefficients or these constants are
going to be all right now let's think
about it so one thing we could think
about is horizontal asymptotes so let's
think about what happens as X approaches
positive or negative infinity well as X
so as as X approaches infinity or X
approaches negative infinity f of X f of
X is going to be approximately equal to
well we're going to look at the highest
degree terms because these are going to
dominate as the magnitude of X the
absolute value of x becomes very large
so f of X is going to be approximately
negative x squared over x squared which
is equal to negative or we could another
way to think about it this is the same
thing as negative 1 so f of X is going
to approach f of X is going to approach
negative 1 in either direction as X
approaches infinity or X approaches
negative infinity so we have a
horizontal asymptote at y equals
negative 1 let's see choice a here it
does look like they have a horizontal
asymptote at y is equal to negative 1
right over there and we can verify that
because each each hash mark is two we go
from two to 0 to negative 2 to negative
4 so this does look like it's at
negative 1 so just based only on the
horizontal asymptote choice a looks good
choice B we have a horizontal asymptote
at y is equal to positive 2 so we can
rule we can rule that out we know that
our horizontal asymptote
as X approaches positive or negative
infinity is at negative 1 y equals
negative 1 here our horizontal asymptote
is at y is equal to 0 the graph
approaches it approaches the x axis from
either above or below so it's not the
horizontal asymptote is not y equals
negative 1 so we can rule that one out
and then similarly over here our
horizontal asymptote is not y equals
negative 1 a horizontal asymptote is y
is equal to 0 so we can rule that one
out and that makes sense because really
they only gave us enough information to
figure out the horizontal asymptote they
didn't give us enough information to
figure out how many roots or what
happens in the interval and all of those
type of things how many zeros and all
that because we don't know what the what
the actual with the actual coefficients
or constants of the quadratic are all we
know is what happens as the x squared
terms dominate this thing is going to
approach negative 1 and so we picked
choice choice a